que moyenne trouve par contre est
modernisée et on ira sur la lune en 1969
les enfants imaginent les moyens de
transport du futur
moi je pense que chaque homme aura un
un motard qui se mettra dans le dos pour
voler un homme volant certains
ingénieurs il y avait déjà pensé en 1964
certains privilégiés préfigure ce que
nous serons demain et piétons demeurent
alors la prévision des piétons de l'air
a fait un flop mais pourtant cette
invention répondait à une attente se
déplacer toujours plus vite en ville
voilà un moyen bien pratique d'éviter
les embouteillages de la circulation
terrestre éviter les bouchons fluidifier
le trafic urbain en 1964 aux états unis
les ingénieurs de ford avait imaginé des
régulateurs de vitesse connecter pour
vous rendre à la ville vous ne pourrez
pas vous tromper
chaque route aura sa couleur quant à la
vitesse de votre voiture
ce n'est pas vous qui en déciderez mais
un régulateur de circulation qui
électroniquement imposera à tous les
véhicules en circulation la vitesse
appropriée
ainsi vous arriverez plus vite en ville
en france dans les années 70 la quête de
nouveaux moyens de transport était
encore la priorité face à l'augmentation
du trafic routier
comment nous déplacerons nous dans les
villes ou dans leur périphérie ou encore
d'une ville à une autre le 4 juin
dernier s'est ouverte à paris transporte
expo tous les systèmes nouveaux y
étaient présentés ce sont les transports
de demain
des prototypes de voitures électriques
mais aussi de transport en commun ultra
moderne était alors présentée et
certaines idées n'ont bizarrement pas eu
de succès comme ces wagons par exemple
lattes et 2000 qui permettra de passer
en marche d'un train à un autre lorsque
les rames seront parfaitement alignés
vous pourrez ainsi changer de direction
sans redescendre sur le quai d'où un
gain de temps appréciable
aujourd'hui la quête de la rapidité est
toujours d'actualité avec par exemple le
lancement d'un service de taxi par
hélicoptère à new york
beaucoup moins fun que les hommes
volants
[Musique]